طيب ينظم علينا في الاستوديو صانع المحتوى
شهاب الهاشمي شهاب صبحك الله بالخير يا
هلا ومرحبا
اليوم تفضل سؤالنا سؤالنا سريع انه سهل
راح يصير عندي قناه يوتيوب بس تفشل تنجح
شنو السر وين الخلطه السحريه الخلطه
السحريه طويل بعمرك هي ان الشخص يعامل
قناه اليوتيوب معامله البزنس كانك فتحت
مثلا متجر الكتروني او مثلا محل في ارض
الواقع ليش لانه يتطلب منك عده امور اهمها
ان دايما يكون عندك بضاعه او عندك محتوى
فيديوهات بشكل مستمر ودائم ثانيا وهذا اهم
الحضور الذهني يعني انا كصانع محتوى الحين
اصعب شيء يواجهني مش تنظيم الوقت مش انه
اطلع افكار انه يكون عندي حضور ذهني في
القناه بمعنى اني اركز شو الموضوع اللي
اطرحه هل هذا يناسب الجمهور سهل انك تطلع
فكره اليوم كل هل الفكره هذه تناسب
الجمهور هل بتحقق لك المشاهدات المطلوبه
هذه التحدي
عندهم قنوات يوتيوب ولكن هي الفكره كيف
تعمل قناتك ربحيه او على الاقل تدر عليك
اموال شو هو اكثر انواع المحتوى على
السوشيال ميديا وعلى اليوتيوب تحديدا اللي
ممكن تدر عليك ارباح هي في فئات اهمها
الفئات التجاريه او المتعلقه بالبزنس
والاموال هذه يكون دخلها اكثر لانها نفس
ما تقولين نيش يعني ما فيها كثير متخصصين
فيديوهات عن عن البزنس والاخبار
الاقتصاديه وكذا هذه اكثر فئه حاليا ربما
في الميناء لانه يختلف في امريكا غيرنا
وتسعيرتها تختلف كذلك لكن اهم شرطين هو
اول شيء ان الشخص قناته يكون فيها الف
مشترك كحد ادنى وانه يا اما يكمل 4000
مشاهده 4000 ساعه مشاهده بنحب معنى ان
المشاهد او السبسكرايبر تشوف فيديو كامل
4000 ساعه والفيديو لازم يكون طويل نوعا
ما حتى يبلش يقدر يحطوا فيه دعايات ويقدر
ارباح عليهم وهو ما في شرط ممكن يكون
الفيديو اقل من مثلا دقيقه بس كل ما زاد
نفس ما ذكرتي ت الارباح لان انت تعطينا
اليوتيوب فرصه انه يعطيك اعلانيه اكثر
اليوم على ماذا يركز من يصنع هذه القناه
الصوره ام الشريحه المستهدفه وشلون اقدم
مال الطبق اللي اخذنا المتلقي في السابق
اخوي عادل كان مهم جدا انه الشخص يركز على
الجوانب الفنيه الصوت والاضاءه والديكور
والخلفيه اليوم لا بساطه اليوم البساطه هي
اللي تخلي الناس يحسون انك واحد منهم
وطبيعي لان كل ما حسوا ان في ارتباط بينهم
وبينك كل ما حبوك اكثر كلما دعموك اكثر كل
ما شاهدوك اكثر فلو حسوا بالتكلم انا ما
اقول ان الواحد ما يتقن عمله لكن فرق بين
الاتقان وبين التكلف انه يكون اوفر درست
الناس يملون منه او يحسونه مفروض عليهم
ان شاء الله نكون
قدر للي حابب انه يعمل او ينشئ قناه
يوتيوب ربحيه بالنسبه لاله شكرا جزيلا لك
شهاب الهاشمي صانع المحتوى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات